&gt;&gt; This is definitely going to be a big issue for us to help Grant tackle. So, I
think we should break this problem-solving down. I also recognize that there are
a lot of words on the screen right now, and that can definitely feel
overwhelming. But if we just take things step-by-step, we can figure this out.
Let's start by talking about what we actually know right now. What information
does the problem give us? Read through this problem statement again, and then
tell me, what do we already know. Do we know how much Grant should spend on
nozzle machinery? Do we know how many nozzles he should make per month? Do we
know how much materials for each nozzle cost? Or do we know how much Grant wants
to spend total on nozzle production?